monfort dire l'actualité internationale
du jeu d'échecs complètement
internationaux ce soir puisque c'est un
spécial pékin chine avec éloi benoît
bonsoir stéphane 40 ans difficile un
retour pas facile puisque la à pékin il
est près de trois heures du matin
donc je suis nous sommes avec un invité
exceptionnel qui revient également de
chine avec moi il s'agit d'une plus fort
maîtres internationaux français actuel
est la première production des modèles
pour la première fois sur des lionel
arnaud hauchard pour soir d'eau on sera
alors comment ça s'est passé
donc ces championnats c'est un
championnat du monde les villes donc à
pékin qui a duré donc quatre jours je
crois exactement avec de très forte aux
équipes ont été en fait la septième et
on a terminé la cinquième place il y
avait surtout trois ou quatre fortes
équipes dont les cliques russes et les
équipes chinoises et pour ce qui leur
est dû les échos les autres équipes
asiatiques étaient était quand même
beaucoup moins importants sont pour
beaucoup beaucoup de travail
il a été très impressionnant on avait
parlé la semaine dernière et le niveau
des finances qui monte
visiblement oui alors c'est vrai qu'un
réservoir de joueurs qui est quand même
vacciné la chine avec plus d'un milliard
et potentiels le douar potentiel donc
c'est remarquable alors alternant des
partis libéraux et le parti de gauche a
exposé en corner pour commencer on m'a
d'abord
gelebart pékin
ces japonais place qui nous amené voir
aucun butin s'est classé débuter le
championnat à son meilleur c'était fou
saison donc c'est légèrement l'interview
intégrale
voilà donc on va voir je vais pas et
qu'ils pensent
les médecins de ville
le manque à gagner puisque reparlerons
équipe
il n'est pas intéressé par cette impasse
en france il faut savoir partir
ma passion jouer quelqu'un vient vous
voir pour embaumer en plus elle capable
de lire des fichiers ou partie discours
au sommet de son émission avec nous on
va démarrer deux parties mais rien ne
dit pas son nom
parti dans l'embarras au phare et dames
sont pas souvent sur une longue
ouverture des marchés
ils veulent pas croire on court trop le
changement de contrôle sera 800 casques
bleus
avant et qui ne comprend pas le sens
une quête d'or le cavalier pour dominer
par la cour le 3 août pour le frac
blanche et avec 3 7 6
en d4 anglaise sont comptés
il se démarque surtout par exemple sur
elle
cavalier 4 2 4 attaquants la dame
blanche
ou quatre ans qui apparaît comme des
cours de change des lycées pour éviter
que ce soit des impayés
ils ont contrôlé le centre
12 500
ce que je n'aime pas ce rendez vous donc
à regarder vers le passé
les écoles en venir à partie par exemple
aussi les sépare la partie a repris les
commandes
sur le long terme pour les cavaliers
trop sèchement 8 6
si les passe droits les flèches pour
cette mission comme si ce qu'ils voient
mais c'est parce que c'est le cas pour
le public et du bloc aux cavaliers toute
la magnificence de travailler
le temps devient d'entre eux subissent
et le doublé jo 2004 par les cadis
pourquoi ils votent pour ces gars je
refusais
sabeg
générer le souvenir
côté libanais ghazi le côté droit de se
croire en même temps sous kadhafi
attaquent la côte du domicile que des
pigs mes locataires
pour les permis à la roumanie les
positions
plusieurs habitations
nous ne l'avons pas suffisant les
échanges de fond sur la santé se
départit secteur technique et non 16
cents je crois que mon échec
pratique
on se rappelait de partout cette
solution s'avère donc 70 sharon chacun
celui qu'on monte donc l'octogénaire
définition précise qu'il sera présent à
barca et nous prenons cette soit pas la
même
non